[Music]
for a long time I was a fan of universal
basic income and the logic I had was
that you know I always hear politicians
talking about let's create jobs for
people that's what we need as jobs more
jobs and as if that's what's gonna solve
the economic problem so the government
is supposed to lend money to a bank who
can then lend money to a corporation who
will then build a factory in order for
people to have jobs do we really need
more jobs in California they're tearing
down houses as we speak because the
houses are in foreclosure and they want
to keep market values high the US
Department of Agriculture burns food
every week in order to keep the prices
of that food high even though there's
people who are starving and people who
need homes we can't just let people have
those homes why because they don't have
jobs so now we're supposed to create
jobs for people to make useless stuff
for other people to buy and plastic crap
that we're gonna throw away or stick in
storage units or end up in landfill just
so those people can have jobs so that we
can justify letting them participate in
the abundance and that's kind of asked
backwards so I thought well well shoot
rather than creating useless jobs what
if we just let people have the stuff
that's in abundance just let people have
the houses what's the problem with this
and you bi kind of goes along that lines
of well if we have more than enough
stuff if we don't need everybody working
all the time then why don't we just let
people have income or at least go to a
four-day work week or a three day work
week or a two day work week or you you
if work is the thing that's scarce then
why don't we meet that out and say oK
we've got these ten days that you're
allowed to work this year so come on
come on to the farm and do that work and
then you know you'll have to find
something else for you to do the rest of
the time but in reality it's not like
that if we were really that efficient
then we wouldn't be destroying the
planet with pollution you know what
we've done is found ways of making stuff
and doing things that require very
little labor but externalize a host of
other problems to a whole lot of other
places so you know we could 3d
or something but but 3d where do you get
the the plastic goop for your 3d printer
what mine in Africa is it coming out of
and what's top soil is it destroying you
know when we're we're going to run out
of topsoil in 60 years it means that
we're not actually using the appropriate
labor-intensive permaculture solutions
in agriculture and all that so first off
that whole idea that we're moving
towards lower employment is a myth
we've faked lower employment through
extremely extractive exploitative
polluting and and and unsustainable
business practices and second I was
giving a talk at uber and I was talking
to them about the problems with their
business model and how they're putting
all these drivers out of work and here
here they are these freelancers working
for the company basically training the
algorithms that will be replacing them
know without any profit participation in
the endgame company and one of the guys
got up and basically quoted back to me a
passage from my own book throwing rocks
at the Google bus we said well what
about universal basic income and when I
heard it coming out of their mouths I
realized oh so universal basic income
isn't just a way to help people have the
money they need to survive and have time
to innovate and come up with other
solutions it's becoming an excuse for
companies like uber to not pay a living
wage to their workers you know so what's
the idea
Oh we'll get the government to print
more money to give it to workers for
them to spend with us so what really
happens what is universal basic income
it's just a way of perpetuating our
roles as consumers at the bottom of the
pyramid not as owners if we're gonna go
to anything I would say what about
universal basic assets what about actual
participation what if the workers owned
the means of production so you don't
just give them a handout so that the
money ends up in the same
corporate coffers and going into the
same shares that's not the point what
what universal basic income does if you
look at the whole model is allows the
people who own the lion's share of our
world to own more and more of it we just
print more money and more of it goes up
to the top that's not the way to get
long-term equity sure social security
welfare the dole all those things are
fine for those in need but it's not a
great long-term economic strategy it's
really just a band-aid on extractive
corporate capitalism how do we get to
extract more we'll just print more cash
for us to extract
[Music]
you